This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. When producer Katie Mingle's dad retired, he began walking. A lot. He'd always been a walker, but with all the new time on his hands, his walking took on a forest, gumpian, fervor. He started doing these really long, multi-day treks through the countryside. And even though he's American, he mostly preferred to walk in the UK. In fact, over the course of several years, he walked the entire length of Great Britain. And on one of these many trips in 2003. I was walking through this beautiful, rolling hills and wooded area, and there were, there were just literally hundreds and hundreds of pheasants and grouse along this trail and you'd walk along and they would fly up in the air.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。当制作人凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）的父亲退休后，他开始散步。走得非常多。他一直都很喜欢散步，但有了这么多空闲时间后，他的散步带有一种阿甘式的狂热。他开始在乡村进行这种真正漫长、历时多天的徒步旅行。尽管他是美国人，但他大多更喜欢在英国散步。事实上，在几年时间里，他走完了整个英国大不列颠的长途。在 2003 年的某次旅行中。我走在这些美丽、起伏的山丘和树林地带，那里有，这条小径沿途字面意思上有成百上千只雉鸡和松鸡，你一边走，它们一边飞到空中。
That's my dad, Jim Mingle. I walked and walked and it got later and later and I realized I couldn't get back to my B&B where I was staying. So I decided I would hitchhike back. Hitchhiking is dangerous, Dad, but go on. I stuck out my thumb and I pulled this Jeep and I hopped in and there was this guy sitting there who all dressed in sort of traditional tweed outfit. It was a funny cap and there was a shotgun outfit. It was a funny cap and there was a shotgun on the rack in the back which you never, ever saw in Britain. And we got to talking and he said he was the gamekeeper for Madonna and Guy Richie. My dad had been walking through Madonna's private estate when he was picked up by her
那是我的父亲，吉姆·明格尔（Jim Mingle）。我一直走一直走，天色越来越晚，我意识到我无法回到我住的 B&B（住宿加早餐旅馆）了。所以我决定搭便车回去。搭便车很危险，爸爸，不过你继续说。我伸出大拇指，拦下了一辆吉普车，我跳了上去，车里坐着一个穿着传统花呢服装的人。戴着一顶滑稽的帽子，后座的架子上还放着一把霰弹枪，这在英国是绝对、绝对看不到的。我们聊了起来，他说他是麦当娜（Madonna）和盖·里奇（Guy Ritchie）的猎场看守人。我父亲当时正走在麦当娜的私人庄园里，就被她的
gamekeeper. Which is a thing a lot of wealthy landowners have in England, a person who manages the hunting activity on their land. Right, so this gamekeeper drove him back to the village where he was staying and dropped him off. And no, his story doesn't end with him meeting Madonna. I wish it did too. And I ask about Madonna how he liked this game pre-keeper liked working for her.
猎场看守人给顺车载了一程。在英国，许多富有的大土地所有者都有这种人，他们负责管理土地上的狩猎活动。没错，这个猎场看守人把他开车送回了他住的村庄，并把他放下。不，他的故事并没有以他见到麦当娜而结束。我也希望是这样。我问关于麦当娜的事，问他是否喜欢这个猎场看守人喜欢为她工作。
He said he loved his job and he thought Madonna was just wonderful. What's your favorite Madonna song, Dad? Oh, I have no idea. I just like the idea of Madonna. I'm not very good at remembering those kinds of things. Now that we've established that Madonna is wonderful and my dad can't name a single one of her songs, you might be asking yourself as I was. Dad, what were you doing in Madonna's backyard?
他说他很热爱他的工作，而且他觉得麦当娜简直太棒了。爸爸，你最喜欢的麦当娜歌曲是什么？哦，我一点也不知道。我只是喜欢麦当娜这个概念。我不大擅长记住那种类型的事情。既然我们已经确定了麦当娜很棒，而我爸爸连她的一首歌都说不出来，你可能也会像我一样问自己。爸爸，你在麦当娜的后院里做什么？
I was walking most of the time across private property. I was walking from one field to the next, climbing over the fence where they are through a gate and going on and this was permitted. It's true, my dad walked the length of Great Britain and was on private property a lot of the time, which is different, obviously, than the way we do things in the US.
我大部分时间都在私人土地上步行。我从一个田地走到另一个田地，翻过围栏，或者穿过大门继续前行，这是被允许的。没错，我父亲走完了整个大不列颠，而且大部分时间都在私人土地上，这显然与我们在美国做事的方式不同。
If you wanted to walk across this country, you'd have to do it on a combination of public trails and roads, and you certainly couldn't cut across Madonna's property. This right in Britain, to walk through private land, is known colloquially as the Right to Rome, and the movement to win this right was started in the 1930s by a rebellious group of young people dressed in army surplus shorts and hiking boots, carrying canvass and rucksacks and canteens. They called themselves, Ramblers.
如果你想徒步穿过这个国家，你必须结合公共小径和道路来完成，而且你肯定不能抄近路穿过麦当娜的财产。在英国，这种穿过私人土地的权利俗称为“漫游权”（Right to Roam），而争取这一权利的运动始于 20世纪 30 年代，由一群穿着军队 surplus（剩余物资）短裤和登山靴、背着帆布背包和水壶的叛逆年轻人发起。他们称自己为“漫游者”（Ramblers）。
Rambler is one of those quite old English words. I don't know where it came from really, but it means walking or hiking in the countryside. This is Rulie Smith, a Rambler slash journalist who says his rambling forefathers and mothers were toiling away in the factories of 1930s Manchester. Manchester was a very grimy town, a very dirty, smokey, horrible environment. A product really of the industrial revolution. Outside Manchester was one of the most beautiful parts of England, an area known as the Peak District.
“Rambler”是那种非常古老的英语单词。我真的不知道它最初来自哪里，但它意味着在乡村散步或徒步旅行。这是鲁利·史密斯（Rulie Smith），一位漫游者兼记者，他表示他的漫游先辈们曾在 20 世纪 30 年代曼彻斯特的工厂里辛苦劳作。曼彻斯特曾是一个非常污秽的城镇，一个非常肮脏、烟雾弥漫、糟糕透顶的环境。这实际上是工业革命的产物。曼彻斯特郊外是英格兰最美丽的地区之一，被称为峰区（Peak District）。
So if you can imagine factory workers in Manchester and Sheffield could actually see these inviting moors from their homes and their workplaces and they weren't allowed to walk on them. It hadn't always been this way. For hundreds of years, an idea of the commons had existed in England. So the commons, they were an integral part of medieval life for the ordinary villager in England. That's Ken Ilguna's author of this land is your land,
如果你能想象一下，曼彻斯特和谢菲尔德的工厂工人实际上可以从他们的家和工作场所看到这些诱人的荒原，但他们却不被允许在上面行走。情况并非一直如此。几百年来，英国一直存在着“公有地”（commons）的概念。因此，公有地是英国普通村民中世纪生活不可或缺的一部分。这是《这片土地是你的土地》一书的作者肯·伊尔古纳斯（Ken Ilgunas），
how we lost the right to Rome Rome and how to take it back. All the land, it was owned by either a king or a lord, but the peasants had very substantial and real rights on these common lands. In this feudal system, kings and lords controlled all the land, and the manor grew enough food to support itself and its tenants. The peasants lived on the land, and the manor grew enough food to support itself and its tenants. The peasants lived on the land,
我们是如何失去漫游权的以及如何夺回它。所有的土地，要么归国王所有，要么归领主所有，但农民在这些公有地上拥有非常实质性和真实的权利。在这种封建制度下，国王和领主控制着所有的土地，庄园产出足够的粮食来养活自己和佃农。农民们住在土地上，庄园产出足够的粮食来养活自己和佃农。农民们住在土地上，
sometimes without written leases, but with assumed rights to use it in exchange for various types of service. They could graze their cattle, cut lumber, they could draw water, they could collect peat, they could use it for a whole bunch of purposes. All of that began to change in the 1400s when wool prices rose across Europe. Landowners wanted it on the profits and in order to graze sheep more efficiently, they
有时没有书面租约，但享有以各种劳务交换使用土地的假定权利。他们可以放牧牛群、砍伐木材、取水、收集泥炭，他们可以将土地用于各种用途。这一切在 15 世纪开始改变，当时整个欧洲的羊毛价格上涨。土地所有者想要获得利润，为了更有效地放牧绵羊，他们
needed to fence off pastures. And that's when we began to see a period of enclosure. Landowners cleared entire villages of people making them homeless and put up little stone walls and hedges to mark the boundaries of their property. In a county called Warwickshire, 61 villages were wiped out before the year 1500. Over the years, Parliament created more and more laws to keep people from using what was once common land. It all ramped up in the 1700s.
需要用栅栏围起牧场。正是在那时，我们开始看到一个圈地时期（enclosure）。土地所有者清理了整个村庄的人口，使他们无家可归，并竖起小石墙和树篱来标记他们财产的边界。在一个叫沃里克郡（Warwickshire）的县，在 1500 年之前就有 61 个村庄被消灭。多年来，议会制定了越来越多的法律，阻止人们使用曾经的公有地。这一切在 18 世纪愈演愈烈。
There was nearly 4,000 acts of parliament between 1760 and 1870. That's a sixth of England that went from common lands to enclosed private property, destroying people's livelihoods in way of life. People were so desperate to continue hunting on this once common land that they came at night and covered their faces in soot for extra camouflage. They became known as the Blacks. And in 1723, Parliament passed the Black Act. So this Black Act, it created 50 offenses that were punishable by death for people who were accessing
在 1760 年到 1870 年之间，有将近 4,000 项议会法令。这意味着英国有六分之一的土地从公有地变成了封闭的私人财产，摧毁了人们的生计和生活方式。人们为了继续在这片曾经的公有地上打猎，绝望到在夜间到来，并将脸上涂满煤灰作为额外的伪装。他们被称为“黑党”（the Blacks）。1723 年，议会通过了《黑人法案》（Black Act）。这个《黑人法案》规定了 50 种罪行，对于那些进入
this land. Eventually, the death penalty for trespassing was done away with, but the land remained closed to the vast majority of people. In the 1800s, Britain industrialized, and people found themselves indoors all day and unable to find places for recreation. England did not have a national park system at this time, and the trails that people could access were extremely limited. Still the people long to be in the hills.
这片土地的人可判处死刑。最终，私闯民宅的死刑被废除了，但土地仍然对绝大多数人关闭。19 世纪，英国实现了工业化，人们发现自己整天待在室内，找不到休闲的地方。当时英国没有国家公园系统，人们可以进入的小径也极其有限。尽管如此，人们依然渴望置身于群山之中。
They walked where they could and trespassed where they couldn't. They climbed over fences and tried to stay hidden from the gamekeepers. And all over England, so-called Rambling Club started to form. The Forest Ramblers Club, the Midlands Institute of Ramblers, the Manchester Rambling Club, there were tons of these walking groups in the late 1800s and early 1900s forming to fight for access and walking rights. They oftentimes had socialist sensibilities, but at the heart, there was a love for walking and a belief that it was their right.
他们在能走的地方走，在不能走的地方私闯。他们翻过栅栏，试图躲避猎场看守人。在整个英国，所谓的“漫游俱乐部”（Rambling Clubs）开始涌现。森林漫游者俱乐部、米德兰兹漫游者研究所、曼彻斯特漫游俱乐部，在 19 世纪末和 20 世纪初，有大量的这类徒步团体成立，为争取通行权和漫游权而战。他们往往带有社会主义情怀，但在核心深处，是对徒步的热爱以及一种坚定的信念，即这是他们的权利。
Access was no longer a matter of survival as it had been in the days when enclosure began. It was about recreation and getting away from the polluted industrial cities. Which brings us back to polluted industrial 1930s Manchester, an rambling club called the British Workers Sports Federation. The British Workers Sports Federation. And in this group was a charismatic rambler named Benny Rothman.
通行权不再像圈地运动开始时那样关乎生存。它关乎娱乐和逃离受污染的工业城市。这就把我们带回了受污染的 19 世纪 30 年代工业化曼彻斯特，一个名为“英国工人体育联合会”（British Workers Sports Federation）的漫游俱乐部。英国工人体育联合会。这个群体中有一位富有魅力的漫游者，名叫本尼·罗斯曼（Benny Rothman）。
A stocky little character, a very broad grin and great sense of humor, and a man of the highest principles. But he was exceptionally short, he was about five foot nothing, as we say. Rulie actually got to know Benny later in life. He was a man who I very much looked up to, although he was very short. So one day back in 1932, a few people from Benny's group tried to take a walk in the Hills near Manchester in that beautiful mountainous area near the city called the Peak District. And they were chased off by a group of gamekeepers and when
一个敦实的小个子，带着灿烂的笑容和极佳的幽默感，是一个有着极高原则的人。但他异常矮小，正如我们所说，他大概只有五英尺高（不到 1.6 米）。鲁利后来在生活中认识了本尼。他是我非常尊敬的人，尽管他个子很矮。所以早在 1932 年的一天，本尼团队的几个人试图在曼彻斯特附近的群山中散步，就在那个被称为峰区的城市附近美丽的群山地区。他们被一群猎场看守人赶走了，当
they got back to their camp Benny Rothman and others said you know if there was enough of us they couldn't stop us. So Benny and the other ramblers came up with an idea. Let's get a huge group together and walk onto this mountain called Kinder Scout. Which was the biggest mountain in this peak district. It was called the Forbidden Mountain. And this area, this was guarded by a whole bunch of gamekeepers.
他们回到营地后，本尼·罗斯曼和其他人说，你知道的，如果我们有足够多的人，他们就阻止不了我们。于是本尼和其他漫游者想出了一个主意。让我们组织一个庞大的群体，走到这座名为金德斯考特（Kinder Scout）的山上。这是峰区最大的山。它被称为“禁山”。这个地区，由一大群猎场看守人把守。
These were intimidating. Men,. I mean they would use telescopes to identify trespassers from afar. They carried these big sticks or clubs that they would sometimes use on trespassers. The British Workers' Sports Federation did not keep their plans to trespass a secret. They gave an interview to the local paper saying, we feel we cannot any longer submit to being deprived of the beauties of the countryside for the convenience of the landowners. Wherever we claim we have a just right to go, we shall trespass in mass and Sunday will be the opening of our campaign. Not everyone was on board.
这些人很有威慑力。我是说，他们会用望远镜从远处识别私闯者。他们带着这些大棍子或大棒，有时会用在私闯者身上。英国工人体育联合会并没有对他们的私闯计划保密。他们接受了当地报纸的采访，称：“我们觉得我们不能再为了土地所有者的方便而忍受被剥夺欣赏乡村美景的权利。凡是我们声称我们有正当权利去的地方，我们都将集体私闯，星期天将是我们行动的开始。”并非所有人都赞同这一点。
More conservative Rambling groups in the area wrote editorials denouncing their plan, saying it would hurt the cause for expanded access to the countryside. One editorial argued that trespassing was fine, but it should be done alone, or with just one or two people, quietly, neatly, and successfully. The police were well aware of the plans to trespass at Kinder Scout and Benny Rothman's role in all of it. And on the day of the event, they tried to serve him with an injunction to keep him from going.
当地更保守的漫游团体发表社论谴责他们的计划，称这会损害扩大乡村通行权的运动。一篇社论认为私闯是可以的，但应该单独进行，或者只带一两个同伴，安静、整洁且成功地进行。警方非常清楚金德斯考特的私闯计划以及本尼·罗斯曼在其中的角色。在活动当天，他们试图向他送达一项禁令，阻止他前往。
The police knew he was coming, and he arrived by bicycle, and they all expected him to come by train, so they were kind of hanging out at the train station. Rothman makes it to the trespass and finds about 400 other people are there too, mostly young people below the age of 21. A lot of men, but some women too. They're wearing old army tops and multicolored sweaters and khaki shorts and worn work boots. This is kind of the standard hiking garb of the day and for whatever reason they carry these enormous rucksacks. They're considered like the thing to do at the time. They co-often wore bear eyes on the heads,
警察知道他要来，他是骑自行车来的，而他们都以为他会坐火车来，所以他们有点在火车站闲逛。罗斯曼成功抵达私闯现场，发现大约还有 400 人也在那里，大多是 21 岁以下的年轻人。有很多男性，但也有一些女性。他们穿着旧军装上衣、色彩斑驳的毛衣、卡其色短裤和磨损的工作靴。这可以说是当时标准的徒步装扮，不知为什么他们还背着巨大的背包。这被认为是当时必须要做的行头。他们通常还在头上戴着贝雷帽，
so it was a very, very motley crew, I think. This motley crew of hikers gathered with their braze and rucksacks at the base of the mountain, and Benny Rothman gave a speech about taking back the rights they lost in the enclosure acts of the 17 and 1800s. And he emphasized that the trespass on Kinderskout was meant to be peaceful. And with that the group set off of the mountain. The other thing they did was sing. They quite often sang when they went out rambling.
所以我觉得这是一群非常、非常杂牌的人。这群形形色色的徒步者背着背包聚集在山脚下，本尼·罗斯曼发表了一讲关于夺回他们在 17 和 18 世纪圈地法案中失去的权利的演讲。他强调，对金德斯考特的私闯意在和平进行。随后，这群人便向山上进发。他们做的另一件事就是唱歌。他们外出漫游时经常唱歌。
And they were singing songs like the Internationale and that sort of thing. And that of course showed their political leaning as well. Communist. The ramblers were in a good mood as they hyped. They sang and talked. There were some police behind them keeping an eye on things and huffing to keep up with the pace of the young walkers. At one point a group of gamekeepers approached them, wagging their sticks, and a small scuffle
他们唱着诸如《国际歌》之类的歌曲。这当然也显示了他们的政治倾向。共产主义者。漫游者们在徒步时心情很好。他们一路唱歌聊天。身后有一些警察在监视情况，并气喘吁吁地跟上年轻步行者的步伐。有一次，一群猎场看守人走近他们，挥舞着木棍，随后爆发了一场小冲突。
ensued. One gamekeeper kind of rolls over and hurts his ankle. That's the extent of the scuffle. Eventually, the ramblers made their way back to the bottom. The trespass had been a success. They'd openly walked on Kinder Scout and no one had been able to stop them. And it probably all would have ended right there, with nothing much gained or lost on either side. If the police hadn't decided to make some arrests.
一个猎场看守人踉跄了一下，扭伤了脚踝。这就是冲突的全部程度。最终，漫游者们回到了山脚下。这次私闯大获成功。他们公开走上了金德斯考特，没有人能够阻止他们。如果警方没有决定逮捕几个人，这一切可能就会在那里结束，双方都不会有什么太大的收获或损失。
Rothman and five other ring leaders, they're arrested. At this time, trespassing wasn't even an arrestable offense, so the police came up with another charge. Insightment to riotous assembly. One rambler got off, but the rest were convicted. came up with another charge. One rambler got off, but the rest were convicted. And they're given prison sentences from two to six months. But when the sentences were handed down by the judge, that actually united the rambler's cause
罗斯曼和其他五名核心领头人被捕了。当时，私闯甚至还不是一项可逮捕的罪名，于是警方想出了另一项指控。煽动聚众骚乱。一名漫游者被释放了，但其余的人都被定罪了。想出了另一项指控。一名漫游者被释放了，但其余的人都被定罪了。他们被判处两到六个月不等的监禁。但当法官宣判刑期时，这实际上团结了漫游者的事业，
and they all thought this was terrible, you know, just for walking on the moors people being sent to prison. Suddenly there was this huge amount of awareness in the general public about walking rights. This was like a national news item at the time. And people were sympathetic. And it would set in motion changes that would transform how England thinks about private property. It's been described as one of the most successful acts of civil disobedience ever in the history of this country. The whole thing is even memorialized in song. There was a guy on the trespass named Jimmy Miller.
他们都认为这太糟糕了，你知道的，仅仅因为在荒原上散步就把人送进监狱。突然之间，广大公众对漫游权的意识大幅提高。这在当时就像是一条全国性的新闻。人们对此表示同情。这将启动一系列变革，改变英格兰对私人财产的看法。它被描述为该国历史上最成功的公民抗命行动之一。整件事甚至被写进了歌里。私闯事件中有一个名叫吉米·米勒（Jimmy Miller）的小伙子。
He eventually became a pretty well-known folk singer in England and changed his name to Yuan Macon. And Yuan wrote the song based on the mass trespass called the Manchester Amall. And you enroute the song, based on the Master's Press, called the Manchester Rambler. Do you know the words? You're not gonna ask me to sing it, are you? I actually, yeah, I really want you to sing it. I can sing the chorus, but I think you should get a recording, really.
他后来成了英国一位相当知名的民谣歌手，并将名字改成了尤恩·麦科尔（Yuan Macon / Ewan MacColl）。尤恩根据这场群众私闯事件写了一首歌，名叫《曼彻斯特漫游者》（The Manchester Rambler）。尤恩根据群众私闯事件写了一首歌，名叫《曼彻斯特漫游者》。你知道歌词吗？你不会让我唱吧？我其实，对，我真的很想让你唱。我可以唱副歌，但我觉得你真应该找个录音。
I'm a Rambler, I'm a Rambler, from Manchester way, I'm a rambler from Manchester way. I get all my pleasure, the heart maul and way. I may be a wage slave on Monday, but I have my freedom on Sunday. The day was just ending and I was descending. It is the anthem for the trespasser in this country and it'll be played at my funeral. After the trespass, the Rambling Groups continued to push for expanded access.
我是个漫游者，我是个漫游者，来自曼彻斯特方向，我是个漫彻斯特来的漫游者。我所有的快乐，都在荒原之路上。我周一可能是个受剥削的工薪奴隶，但我周日拥有自由。白昼方尽，我正下山。这是这个国家私游者的赞歌，它将在我的葬礼上播放。私闯事件发生后，漫游者团体继续推动扩大通行权。
There were more trespasses. In a 1951, when Britain opened its first national park, it was in the peak district where the Kindre Scout trespass took place. This was no accident. Years of negotiations between the Ramblers and the landowners and legislators in the area had paved the way. But it wasn't until the year 2000
发生了更多的私闯事件。1951 年，当英国开放其第一个国家公园时，它就位于金德斯考特私闯事件发生的峰区。这绝非偶然。漫游者与该地区的土地所有者和立法者经过多年的谈判，为这一切铺平了道路。但直到 2000 年，
that the Ramblers got what they'd always wanted. An act of parliament that opened up huge swaths of the country where people could roam free. The countryside and rights of way act, and that opened up mountains, moors, heaths, downs. Those are just kind of fancy English words for unimproved grassland. And now we do have the right to roam in open country which is what those lads in 1932 were fighting for. The 2000 act opened up about 7% of the land in England and 21% in Wales on which you are free to roam meaning you don't even have to stay on a trail. You can truly just wander around. And 7% may not sound like a lot. But between that and other designated
漫游者们才得到了他们一直想要的东西。一项国会法令，开放了该国大片土地，人们可以在那里自由漫游。《乡村与通行权法案》（Countryside and Rights of Way Act），该法案开放了山脉、荒原、石楠荒地、丘陵。这些只是一些花哨的英语词汇，指的是未开垦的草地。现在我们在开阔的乡村确实拥有了漫游权，正是 1932 年那些小伙子们为之奋斗的目标。2000 年的法案开放了英格兰约 7% 和威尔士 21% 的土地，供人们自由漫游，这意味着你甚至不必呆在小径上。你真的可以四处闲逛。7%听起来可能不多。但在那之后与其他指定
trails, where there are more restrictions, you can now pretty easily walk across England, just like Katie's dad did. A small footnote. The year after my dad rambled across Madonna's property, she actually sued to keep people from wandering around out there. The government ended up allowing her to close off a lot of her estate, but did keep some small amount of it open to ramblers. Madonna wasn't the only person with concerns about ramblers. When the countryside and rights of way act past, a lot of landowners feared the worst. You know, everyone was worried about people sniffing glue out on the countryside and people being mowed down by tractors and wildly fornicating.
有更多限制的小径相比，你现在可以非常轻松地徒步穿过英格兰，就像凯蒂的爸爸做的那样。一个小花絮。在我爸爸在麦当娜的地产上漫游的一年后，她实际上起诉禁止人们在那里闲逛。政府最终允许她关闭她的大部分庄园，但确实保留了其中一小部分向漫游者开放。麦当娜并不是唯一对漫游者有顾虑的人。当《乡村与通行权法案》通过时，许多土地所有者担心最坏的情况发生。你知道，每个人都担心人们在乡村吸食强力胶，担心被拖拉机碾压，还有疯狂地乱交。
Like, this was all in the newspapers. Like, people were really worried, but none of that stuff turned out to be true. In addition to Britain, a bunch of other European countries also have partial right to Rome systems, meaning some but not all private property is accessible to walkers. But then there are countries where the right is even further expanded. Norway, Finland, Sweden has this thing called Alamansrotten, which means every man's right. And this means you can walk over Kaupp man's right, and this means you can walk over cow pasture, this means you can walk through the woods, this means you can access virtually
就像，这些都在报纸上。就像，人们真的很担心，但这些事情最终都没有发生。除了英国，其他许多欧洲国家也有部分的漫游权系统，这意味着步行者可以进入部分但不是全部的私人财产。但也有一些国家的这种权利得到了进一步扩大。挪威、芬兰、瑞典有种叫“Allemansrätten”的东西，意思是“每个人的权利”（every man's right）。这意味着你可以走过（每个人的权利），这意味着你可以走过牛棚牧场，这意味着你可以穿过树林，这意味着你可以进入几乎
the whole countryside. In the United States we have a system of national and state parks, but we don't have any rights to wander through private property, And in some places, you might even get shot for doing it. The idea of opening up private land to the public seems almost un-American, but this wasn't always the case. Yeah, this is kind of like a forgotten chapter of American history. Americans who were un-inslaived, we had the right to roam from the colonial days up until the Civil War. In the early days of this country, it was common practice to hunt and fish on private land if it wasn't enclosed by offense. In fact, the Pennsylvania delegation to the Constitution
整个乡村。在美国，我们有国家公园和州立公园系统，但我们没有任何在私人财产中漫游的权利，在某些地方，你甚至可能会因此被枪击。向公众开放私人土地的想法似乎有些极不美国化，但情况并非一直如此。是的，这有点像是美国历史中被遗忘的一章。未被奴役的美国人，从殖民地时期一直到内战，我们都享有漫游权。在这个国家的早期，如果在没有用栅栏围起来的私人土地上打猎和捕鱼是常见做法。事实上，宪法的宾夕法尼亚州代表团
even tried to get this enshrined in the Bill of Rights. That's how important this was to early Americans. Nearly a century later, in an 1862 essay entitled Walking, Henry David Thoreau wrote that he feared that one day, quote, walking over the surface of God's earth shall be construed to mean trespassing on some gentleman's grounds. This day may have come even sooner than Thoreau feared. Kenogunas says our concept of private property began to change just a few years later
甚至试图将其写入《权利法案》。这对早期美国人来说是多么重要。近一个世纪后的 1862 年，亨利·戴维·梭罗（Henry David Thoreau）在一篇名为《漫步》（Walking）的文章中写道，他担心总有一天，引用：“在上帝大地的表面上行走，将被解释为侵入某些绅士的土地。”这一天可能比梭罗所担心的还要早到来。肯·伊尔古纳斯说，我们的私有财产概念在几年后开始改变，
after the Civil War, partly because of the end of slavery. One perfect example of this is in 1865. It's the Louisiana legislature. And after the war, they passed this resolution. They acknowledged the end of the war and they also do something else. They criminalize trespassing. Now, why would they do that right after the Civil War? I think I know why.
就在内战之后，部分原因是奴隶制的废止。一个典型的例子是在 1865 年。路易斯安那州议会。战后，他们通过了这项决议。他们承认战争已经结束，同时他们还做了另一件事。他们将私闯民宅定为犯罪。现在，他们为什么要在内战结束后这样做呢？我想我知道为什么。
They did that because now you had a whole bunch of free and independent black people. There were other reasons as well. As Native Americans were forced onto reservations, land grants to the Railroads and the homestead act of 1862 turned great swaths of public land to private ownership and then came barbed wire. Fences became a lot cheaper so you could put fences up for livestock so suddenly a whole bunch more of the country is enclosed. You have a diversified economy, so people are no longer relying on the land for
他们这样做是因为现在有了一大群自由且独立的黑人。还有其他原因。随着美洲原住民被驱逐到保留地，对铁路的土地赠与以及 1862 年的《宅地法》（Homestead Act）将大片公共土地变成了私有财产，随之而来的是带刺铁丝网。栅栏变得便宜得多，因此你可以为牲畜竖起栅栏，突然之间，这个国家的很大一部分都被圈起来了。你拥有了多元化的经济，所以人们不再像以前那样过度依赖土地来
hunting and fishing and gathering as much as they used to. So when people start chipping away at access rights, you don't have an impassioned group of proponents fighting to maintain their access rights. But Ken Ogunas thinks we should be fighting for recreational access in this country, where a lot of our public land is concentrated in places that are hard for most people to get to. For instance, Alaska has 329 million acres of our public land. That's 41% of all public land. You look at the five states with the highest percentages of public land.
狩猎、捕鱼和采集。因此，当人们开始蚕食通行权时，你没有一群充满激情支持者为了维护他们的通行权而战。但肯·伊尔古纳斯认为，我们应该为这个国家的休闲通行权而战，因为我们的大部分公共土地都集中在大多数人很难到达的地方。例如，阿拉斯加拥有我们 3.29 亿英亩的公共土地。占所有公共土地的 41%。你看看公共土地百分比最高的五个州。
That's Alaska, Nevada, Utah, Idaho, Wyoming. All this land is in states where there aren't that many people. Ilgunas believes a right to roam system could help connect all these disparate pieces of public land and give us a sense of ownership. I think if we bring in a system like the right to roam, you know, we're still going to look at the land as if it's someone's, but I think we'll also begin to look at it as if it's sort of hours. And for what it's worth, my dad agrees. He says there's something really special about being able to walk wherever you want. I thought the whole concept of being able to walk respectfully across
那是阿拉斯加、内华达州、犹他州、爱达荷州、怀俄明州。所有这些土地都在人口不那么多的州。伊尔古纳斯相信，漫游权系统可以帮助连接所有这些分散的公共土地，并给我们一种归属感。我想如果我们引入像漫游权这样的系统，你知道，我们仍然会把这片土地看作是某人的，但我也认为我们会开始把它看作是某种程度上属于我们的。无论如何，我爸爸表示赞同。他说，能够随心所欲地走到任何你想去的地方，有一种非常特别的感觉。我认为能够恭敬地走过
private land was extraordinary and it was something that just doesn't exist here. We have a lot of public land where you can walk in the U.S. but this seemed very different. There were so many routes and trails to choose from. It felt like the whole country was open to you. These days, if you ramble across the open grasslands of England or Wales, you'll see the remnants of enclosure, the stone walls and fences. And you'll also see the things meant to help you get past these barriers, the styles, which are step ladders to help you get over fences, the so-called kissing gates, which are these shaped openings that people can walk through, but livestock cannot.
私人土地的整个概念是非凡的，这是这里根本不存在的东西。我们在美国有很多可以散步的公共土地，但这看起来非常不同。有那么多的路线和小径可供选择。感觉整个国度都对你敞开。如今，如果你在英格兰或威尔士开阔的草地上漫游，你会看到圈地运动的遗迹，石墙和栅栏。你还会看到旨在帮助你越过这些障碍的设施，比如stile（供人翻越篱笆的登梯），这是帮助你翻过栅栏的阶梯，还有所谓的“接吻门”（kissing gates），这些是人们可以通过但牲畜无法通过的特定形状的开口。
Because the fences aren't there to stop you anymore. You just hop over and continue on your way. Some places go beyond a right to roam and offer free shelter to a weary rambler. We visit Bothy's, up next. After England and Wales began implementing their countryside and rights of way act, Scotland, I love Scotland, they decided to take things a step further. So in 2003, they passed their own Land Reform Act, and it did a bunch of things, but first and foremost, it codified a long tradition of public access. Basically, if people are respectful of other people and property, they can roam even more
因为栅栏不再是为了阻止你。你只需跳过去，继续你的旅程。有些地方超越了漫游权，为疲惫的漫游者提供免费庇护所。我们接下来将探访“Bothy”（山间小屋）。在英格兰和威尔士开始实施他们的乡村与通行权法案后，苏格兰，我爱苏格兰，他们决定将事情推进一步。因此，在 2003 年，他们通过了自己的《土地改革法案》（Land Reform Act），该法案做了很多事情，但首要的是，它将长期的公众通行传统编纂成了法律。基本上，如果人们尊重他人和财产，他们就可以在北方的私人土地上更加自由地漫游。
freely on private land up north. And it's part of a larger ethos about accessibility exemplified by these little buildings called Bothy's, a regional phenomenon that Kurt Colstead is here to tell us about. So historically, a Bothy was typically a small cottage for farm workers, but rural depopulation led to a lot of these being abandoned. So travelers who saw they were empty started spinning the nights in them. So the first time I ever encountered the word Bothy was in Starling, Scotland, and I ate it at a place for lunch called the coffee bothy, which I think is not these sort of things,
这是关于可及性的更广泛精神的一部分，由这些被称为“Bothy”的小建筑所体现，柯特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Colstead）将为我们讲述这一地区现象。因此，从历史上看，Bothy 通常是农场工人的一个小村舍，但农村人口外流导致其中许多被废弃。因此，看到它们空置的旅行者开始在里面过夜。所以我第一次遇到“Bothy”这个词是在苏格兰斯特灵（Starling / Stirling），我在一个叫“咖啡 Bothy”的地方吃午饭，我想这不是那种地方，
but it's kind of like us saying that I ate it at a pizza hut last night. Yeah, exactly, right. So Bothy has this broader association of these old, you know, old small buildings on farm steds. But yeah, it now is sort of grown to have this larger meaning of also being these places to stay. So if you bump into a traveler and say, hey, I'm staying at the Bothy, they'll probably know what you mean. Right, right. Cool. So Bothy's can be found across the British Isles,
但这有点像我们说我昨晚在必胜客（Pizza Hut）吃饭一样。对，没错。因此，Bothy 与这些古老的、你知道的，农庄里古老的小建筑有更广泛的联系。但是的，它现在已经发展出了更大的含义，也成为了这些住宿的地方。所以如果你偶遇一个旅行者并说，嘿，我住在 Bothy 里，他们大概会知道你的意思。没错，没错。太酷了。因此，Bothy 遍布不列颠群岛，
but especially in the Scottish Highlands. And while they're publicly accessible, most are still on private property. And the owners just let ramblers sleep on their land, and Bothy's that they own. They do. Over time, a lot of these land owners have actually really embraced the tradition, leaving buildings unlocked and open for use. But it's a community effort too. There are volunteers who help take care of and manage bothy's through the Mountain Bothy Association, which is a Scottish charity. So I'm picturing these mostly as like small, dark stone cottages, angled roofs, little chimneys
但在苏格兰高地尤为常见。虽然它们是公共可访问的，但大多数仍然在私人土地上。业主只是让漫游者在他们的土地上以及他们拥有的 Bothy 里睡觉。确实如此。随着时间的推移，许多土地所有者实际上真正接受了这一传统，保持建筑不上锁并开放供人使用。但这也是一个社区的努力。有志愿者通过苏格兰慈善机构“山地 Bothy 协会”（Mountain Bothy Association）帮助照顾和管理 Bothy。所以我把这些主要想象成小的、黑暗的石头村舍，斜屋顶，小烟囱
on rolling, grassy hillside, so that's the image I'm going to complete. Is that about right? Yeah, that's, yeah. So a lot of them look exactly like what you're imagining, but not all of them. There's actually a pretty wide variety in terms of their settings and their architecture. Some are inland, others still on the beaches. Some used to be things like post offices or schools. And there's this one out in the coastal cliffs of sky called the lookout. That was actually built to be a Coast Guard station.
坐落在起伏的草地山坡上，这就是我脑海中的完整画面。差不多是这样吗？对，就是这样。所以它们中的许多看起来完全就像你想象的那样，但并非全部。在它们的环境和建筑方面，实际上存在着相当广泛的多样性。有些在内陆，有些则在海滩上。有些以前是邮局或学校之类的东西。斯凯岛（Sky）的海滨悬崖上有一个叫“瞭望台”（the lookout）的地方。那其实是作为海岸警卫队哨所建造的。
That has these big windows and these really awesome panoramic views. And it comes with binoculars, wildlife identification charts and this logbook for people who wanna watch the dolphins and the whales. So there's no reservations, you just ramble up and you can stay in one of these places. That's the idea.
那里有大窗户和真正棒极了的全景视野。里面还配有双筒望远镜、野生动物识别图表以及供想要观察海豚和鲸鱼的人使用的航海日志。所以不需要预订，你只需漫步过去，就可以住在这些地方之一。这就是主意。
So you have to find them first. And that wasn't always easy to do. For decades, it was mainly a word of mouth system. And then a few years back, the Mountain Bothy Association started putting maps up online, making it easier for people to plan out their trips and get to them. So you get nature, you get views, they're free. Where do you sign up? I mean, that's pretty stunning.
所以你必须先找到它们。这并不总是容易做到。几十年前，这主要是一个靠口碑相传的系统。然后几年前，山地 Bothy 协会开始在网上发布地图，使人们更容易计划他们的旅行并到达那里。所以你有大自然，有风景，它们是免费的。你在哪里注册？我的意思是，这真是太棒了。
Well, you don't have to sign up, which is the beauty of it. But I should warn you that bodies can be pretty minimalist at times, some have sleeping platforms and stoves and little libraries, things like that, but they don't typically have running water or much insulation. Still, I mean, it is a really impressive system
嗯，你不需要注册，这就是它的美妙之处。但我必须警告你，Bothy 有时可能非常极简，有些有睡眠平台、炉灶和小图书馆之类的东西，但它们通常没有自来水或太多保温设施。尽管如此，我的意思是，这确实是一个令人印象深刻的系统，
and a great way to repurpose old buildings that are not otherwise in use. And it works especially well in Scotland where really remote places can be accessed in part thanks to really permissive roaming laws. How do I know I'm staying in a designated botty on someone's land rather than just accidentally sleeping in their garden shed? You know, I'm not sure. I didn't see anything about this, what I was reading about them. But I wonder, if you did just accidentally stay in an abandoned building,
也是重新利用原本闲置的老旧建筑的好方法。这在苏格兰尤其有效，在苏格兰，由于真正宽容的漫游法律，偏远地区的部分地方可以被访问。我怎么知道我住在某人土地上指定的 Bothy 里，而不是不小心睡在他们的花园棚里呢？你知道，我不确定。我读到它们的时候没看到关于这方面的任何内容。但我想，如果你真的不小心住进了一座废弃的建筑，
I mean, that's how Bought Being started, right? That was sort of the origin of it. Is this a system that's unique to Scotland? Not entirely. The US and Canada, Australia, New Zealand, and actually a lot of northern European countries also have their own versions. That said, in many places,
我的意思是，Bothy 就是这样开始的，对吧？那正是它的起源。这是一个苏格兰独有的系统吗？不完全是。美国、加拿大、澳大利亚、话新西兰，实际上还有许多北欧国家也有他们自己的版本。话虽如此，在许多地方，
they're even more rustic, and they're often owned and operated by government agencies and set up on public lands. Right, and we have a much more divided system here of public versus private land. When it comes to private property, you really have to watch out for those no trespassing sides and heed their warning. Exactly. While in Scotland, people really have to watch out for those no trespassing sides and heed their warning.
它们甚至更简陋，通常由政府机构拥有和运营，并建在公共土地上。没错，我们这里有一个更加分裂的公共与私人土地系统。当涉及到私人财产时，你真的必须提防那些“严禁私闯”的标志并听从他们的警告。完全正确。而在苏格兰，人们真的可以走出去，以这个词最真实的含义去漫游。如果他们在路上碰巧遇到一个 Bothy，他们就可以直接走进去。听众可以在我们的网站 99pi.org 上找到 Bothy 的图片，以及 Bothy 网络地图和其他信息的链接。
Exactly. While in Scotland, people really can just go out and wander in the truest sense of the word. And if they happen to come across a botty along the way, they can just walk right in. And listeners can find images of bothies as well as links to maps and other information about the botty network. And an article that just published on our website, it's at 99pi.org. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Senior Producer Katie Mingle, Mix and Tech
以及刚刚在我们网站上发表的一篇文章，网址是 99pi.org。本周的 99% Invisible 由高级制作人凯蒂·明格尔制作，混音和技术制作由谢里夫·尤素夫（Sharif Yusuf）完成，音乐由肖恩·里豪（Sean Rihau）创作。其他的 99PI 漫游者还有我们的数字总监柯特·科尔斯特德、高级编辑德兰妮·霍尔（Delaney Hall）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、薇薇安·李（Vivian Lee）、艾弗里·特罗法明（Avery Trophamine）、泰兰·马扎（Terran Mazza），以及我罗曼·马尔斯。特别感谢为我们提供这个故事灵感的吉姆·明格尔，以及来自漫游者协会（Ramblers Association）的凯特·阿什布鲁克（Kate Ashbrook），该协会一直在为英格兰和威尔士的步行权而战。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心广播街（Radio Row）制作。99% Invisible 是 PRX 旗下 RadioTopia 的成员，这是一个由播客中极具创新性的节目组成的激烈独立的集体。你可以在 radiotopia.fm 上找到它们。
Production by Sharif Yusuf, Music by Sean Rihau. The other 99PI Ramblers, our digital director Kirk Cole Stead senior editor, Delaney Hall, Joe Rosenberg, Emmett Fitzgerald Vivian Lee, Avery Trophamine, Terran Mazza, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to Jim Mingle, who gave us the idea for this story, and Kate Ashbrook from the Ramblers Association, which continues to fight for walking rights in England and Wales. We are a project of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. 99% of visible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. You can find them all that radiotopia.fm.
你可以在 Facebook 上找到该节目并加入关于该程序的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上 @ 我，账号是 Roman Mars，@ 节目组是 99PI org。我们也在 Instagram、Tumblr 和 Reddit 上。但我邀请你漫步到我们肥沃的设计故事土地上。我们在 99pi.org。[♪ 尾声音乐播放中 [♪ [♪ 尾声音乐播放中 [♪ 你。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击抄本中的任何句子发表评论。
You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But I invite you to ramble on over to our fertile land of design stories. We're at 99pi.org. [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以在Facebook上找到本节目并参与讨论。您可以在推特上@我Roman Mars，或@节目官方账号99PI org。我们也在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上。但我邀请您闲逛到我们设计故事的肥沃土地上。我们在99pi.org。[♪ 片尾音乐播放 [♪ [♪ 片尾音乐播放 [♪ 本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。